[موسيقى]
في شوارع القاهرة الصاخبة الصاخبة ،
هذا ما يبدو عليه رمضان ، وبالنسبة
لبائعي هذه الفوانيس ذات الألوان الزاهية
، فإن كلمة Mo هي
[موسيقى]
بشكل عام أكثر الفانوس شهرة لدينا هو
محمد صلاح ، العالم مجنون
به ، فهناك عدة أنواع سرقها طفل
واحد خشبي وآخر كبير
وليس من المستغرب لأنه في هذا
الجزء من فوانيس البلدة مصرية مثل
صلاح نفسه
فوانيس حموساسة رمادا لفترة
طويلة احتفل الناس برمضان
بالفوانيس والديكورات هذه
تقاليد مصرية
وعلى الرغم من التضخم والارتفاع  فيما يتعلق
بتكلفة كرات القدم الحية ،
يجلب الملك المصري الأمل إلى المزيد من السبل التي
ربما يعلم أن هناك تفاؤلًا في
محمد صلاح ، فقد خلق جوًا جيدًا
[موسيقى]
40 عامًا من تشكيل علب
الفرح الصغيرة هذه ، علمت ناسا شيئًا واحدًا لا يمكن
مقارنته بالمصري  الفوانيس
[موسيقى]
الفوانيس الصينية تعتبر
لعب اطفال وهذا هو
فانوس رمضان الشرعي
[موسيقى].